this morning president biden continues
his visit to south korea where he's met
with the country's newly inaugurated
president and has reaffirmed america's
long-standing commitment to that
nation's security back here at home film
and tv projects by or about south
koreans have suddenly been in the
spotlight including a powerful new
series on apple tv that's already been
renewed for a second season pachinko is
both an epic saga of korean history and
an intimate look at one family's
experience through the generations
michelle miller has the story
the lighthearted mood of pachinko's
opening credits gives little away to the
dark past of the series plotline
but it dares to hope
people are going to be really touched
and it's going to move a lot of people's
emotions
it did that for minha kim the virtually
unknown actor who won the lead role you
didn't have a lot of experience
in the industry before getting this part
this is the most significant role that i
had in my life
she plays soonja the matriarch of a poor
korean family
her star turn and apple tv's pachinko is
giving americans a history lesson a
chance for a lot of people around the
world to get to know the culture of
korea they get to know our history a
history telling the story of japanese
occupation between 1910 and 1945 koreans
were denied their language their culture
they were even forced to take on
japanese names many died in protest and
hundreds of thousands of others were
shipped into hard labor or prostitution
pachinko sunja grows up during that
colonial rule
in the middle of this like so much
horrible things are happening around
them they were trying to
keep the things
stable with their love i think that's
the most powerful message that we have
while period dramas like bridgerton have
become big hits for all of you hollywood
doesn't usually invest in sweeping
historical shows
that aren't spoken in english
but pachinko is enjoying both critical
and popular success
not unlike oscar winners parasite and
menari please stand what a beautiful
family
glad you're here
and one of the most watched series on
netflix squid game
there's no easy way to say this
you're not getting the bump not this
year a trilingual show on a major
streamer or broadcaster hadn't been done
before pachinko showrunner sue hugh had
an uphill climb to find backing if
there's nothing else i'd like to go to
my daughter's wedding but drew
inspiration from the godfather trilogy
and its focus on family i watched the
godfather when i was 12 years old and it
really is the film that made me want to
be a filmmaker but then when i think
about pachinko you know this is not a
crime show and but what i loved about
the godfathers in some ways even though
crime was its way it really is about
this family especially godfather too i
just thought it was the way it weaved
together past and present and created a
very literary dialogue it became a model
in terms of structure for us
this storyline continues through a
second and third generation sunji's son
owner of a gaming pachinko parlor and
his son solomon at the end of the day
your own tally defies gravity a yale
graduate trying to earn respect beyond
the insular prejudices of 1980s tokyo
the elder sunja is played by oscar
winner yoon jung young and the oscar
goes to
jejung yoon
who won best supporting actress for her
role last year in menari thanks to the
academy
members that who vote for me she was so
like legendary actors in korea before
that so when i heard that yj is going to
be the elder sanjay i was like oh my god
that's a big thing i have to be really
good
neither met before filming
you just had to act it out on faith yes
just but that worked
so
i really had a very strong faith to her
and to the baby sanja
[Music]
for kim the story of sunja runs deep why
did you connect with her it's kind of
abnormal for me to just connect with
sanjay right away after i read the
script right before that i had to think
about that character and myself and i
have to
find out the connections between them
and me but this one was very different i
just felt it right away that she's
fragile she's so fragile
and delicate
but she's somehow very strong
the wedding scene
what happened when you read that scene
in korea the rice and the food is kind
of like another language for us like
meal is really really important
especially for the white rice and that
wedding scene
it means a lot like it means everything
that's why
sanja cried so hard
at that night of the wedding day because
it's so
like my grandmother told me it was so
hard to get the white rice at that time
and her grandmother's stories at that
time in korea painted a fuller picture
because it was a colonial era so the
government took all the rights from the
people in korea it was unbelievable it
was like
how did you suffer and she said it was
just natural everybody did it so
it was not only me doing that
despite being told in korean japanese
and very little
english pachinko has found its american
audience
there's so many
more stories and topics to tell the
audience in korea not only in korea but
around the asian culture
so i think it's a great step to move
forward
for people around the world to
get to know each other
it's
so amazing to see how audiences are are
open these days to language or to shows
and movies that are not in english
because that opens the landscape of what
you can tell in such a big way family is
universal and story and family dramas
and tragedies and everything else i mean
ever but no matter where you live
everybody goes through
yeah it doesn't matter the language yeah
it's storytelling and it's the heart at
the center of it i thought it was so
interesting when she compared it to the
godfather it's so true that's exactly
what it is if you watch the way you are
going back and forth and it's all just
woven together beautifully it transcends
cultures yeah there's that famous line
about the godfather there's only one
reason why that movie was successful one
and only it was about family yeah